on today's show we talked to a 60 year
old man who's struggling with what to do
next
we talked to a young man who wants to be
a great dad and he's getting married
and she's bringing a daughter in two and
he wants to be a great stepdad too
we also talk to a woman who's got two
adopted kids
struggling with work struggling with
their marriage and she's thinking she
might want to walk away
stay tuned hey
what is up this is delony with the dr
john delonay show
hope you're doing awesome awesome is
such a dramatic word that people who
work with high school kids use on a
regular basis so i'm not going to use it
anymore hope you're doing well
hope your family's good i hope you're
healthy i'm glad you're walking
alongside us listening to watching the
show today however you're consuming this
we take your calls on mental health on
your
wellness on your relationships on your
marriage on what's going on in your life
good stuff bad stuff
tough stuff hard stuff all all of it
we're so glad that you're here
sometimes on the show we talk about
really positive things sometimes we talk
about hard hard truths
and sometimes i just have to admit some
things
so after one of my podcasts
the other day i was driving home from
work alone
in my car and
my buddy called me from texas and
he said the following i've got something
that's really annoying for your annoying
part segment
and i was like great what is it and he
said you
you are the annoying part because you
said the words
literally three times in a podcast
and i was like dude i didn't say that i
would never say that because it violates
one of my core tenants about overuse of
adverbs
and he said man you did it and it's
ridiculous it was annoying and so
i would like to call you up being
annoying and so
i think it's crazy how many
adverbs we use for those of you don't
know adverbs on the whole are l y words
and so
an average sentence these days is
something like
it was terribly embarrassingly ugly
how weirdly and spaciously she moved
around the room
with her hairy and
horrifyingly horrible clothes
right like that like what are you saying
just say what you're gonna say
and then we all use the word literally
wrong so i hereby declare
internet podcasts universe whatever
a moratorium on adverbs let's just say
this
she was really sad not she was terribly
terrifyingly sad
she was really bummed man that's it
we're gonna reset
starting today control alt delete on all
language use
in the known universe no more adverbs
and
here's another thing i will begin
sending out
10 free books that's probably a lot five
free books every time i use an adverb
we can just kelly's gonna keep a jar we
gotta fix the language man i'm just an
idiot it sounds awful
and i use the word literally three times
so every adverb i'm gonna send out five
free books to people on the internet
all right today's show is gonna be fun
and hard and exciting all at the same
time so let's get right to the phones
let's go to brian
in san antonio brian how in the world
are we doing man
i'm doing okay sir you i'm doing okay as
well
so man for our listeners here
i want to let them know how i got to
know you and
um how you and i talked for a few
minutes briefly i think a week or two
ago
and um i was so grateful that uh you're
willing to reach out and
catch back up with me on this show so we
can talk a little bit more
um i was co-hosting the dave ramsey show
with
with dave and you called in
and said you were struggling with some
things and
we got up against a break in that in
that call and
we answered the financial part of that
question but i had this sneaking
suspense in my guts that there was way
way more to that call
and um gratefully off the air you talked
to kelly about it
and um you were willing to come back and
chat with me a little bit further man so
i want to tell you i'm
i've been thinking about you all week
and i'm glad that you uh reached back
out and i'm glad that we get to spend um
some more time together
i appreciate that man so um welcome me
back
tell me what's going on in your in your
world and your heart and your mind
everything
uh when i called you all i was reaching
out because
the few times that i've listened to dave
it just seems like he
really cares about the people he talks
to on the phone yeah
and i was looking for somebody to give
me a little
direction yeah and uh as talking to
y'all i guess y'all you
came up that i'm having issues
in my head a little bit and you wanted
to talk to me some more about that
i mean i just i'm just
looking for some help getting myself
straightened out you know i'm 60 years
old and i need
to get my head in the right place and my
finances in the right place and
get ready for whatever's coming on after
this i guess
so man you you said a lot there without
saying very much so when you say get
your head right
tell me what's going like we're here
together man just be honest and
and be open as as vulnerable as you feel
comfortable being but what's going on
in your head uh
mostly it's just uh
i mean i like what i do where i work and
everything
but i have a hard time getting up and
getting there and i'm just tired all the
time
yeah i'm just i'm not i don't know if
it's physical or mental or a combination
of both
just you know it's just
it's just hard to get up and live every
day and
on the days off it's really hard i don't
get much accomplished because i just
i just drag all day long so
you're 60 now take me back to brian
who's 20
i don't i don't when i was 20 i
just moved to texas worked the job
that you know required lots of hours and
had no issues
getting up and working and spending as
many hours as i needed to on the job
and but brian at 20 did not plan for
brian at 60
no nor at 30 or 40 or so
that's i'm sitting here at 60
with not a plan on how i'm gonna
keep on keeping on when i can't get to
work and make a paycheck every day
yeah so you ever been married man
uh for five years tell me about that
when'd you get married i was 30 30.
and so you got married at 30 and five
years so what happened
with that relationship um
i got her pregnant and i thought getting
married was the right thing to do
after we got married she said that
i talked her into it she didn't really
want to be married and she pretty much
from the get-go wanted to
be divorced so fought it for five years
and then
finally she had all she could take and
said that's it and
we split the blanket so take me back to
brian as a ten-year-old were you born
and raised and tell me about your folks
yeah i was born and raised in northern
indiana
um my folks were some of the best people
in the world
and my dad was an incredible man
you know they cared about their kids
they took care of us
i don't um you know
they both worked what brought you to
texas
uh i grew up on a farm and after doing
that
working on another farm when i got out
of school i
wanted to try something different i had
some friends that i went to school with
that live down here and
they invited me down i found a job and
just
ended up down here i love texas it's a
great place yeah
i agree i agree i talk about it all too
much on this show man
that's where i was born and raised so um
so you mentioned you had a kid
um tell me about your kid uh
i think that he's a great human being
he's
30 years old now yeah uh you know he's
everybody that has deals with him and
his life has good things to say about
him i
i'm proud to be his dad
how often do you get to see him uh
uh with this covid thing and stuff it's
we've only been able to get together a
couple times in the last year but
before that you know several times a
year we'd
i'd go up there he'd come down here yeah
are you a granddad
no no someday
uh you know with the way the world is
now
i don't think that's in the plans what
does that mean
uh i i just it seems that
a lot of the people in that 30 year old
and younger
feel like the raising the kids is
just too much to handle and
i kind of have to agree that raising
kids is not the easiest thing but it's
the best thing that ever happened to me
that's right well i'll keep my
my fingers crossed for you so you fast
forward
here you're 60 tell folks what you do
for a living
i work for the state and uh
maintenance job that keeps me outdoors
a lot and i'm down here in the hill
country where it's beautiful
and so when you say you just wake up
every day you hurt you're tired all the
time
have you gone to see a doctor and get
checked out physically
uh yeah and pretty much all they say is
we've got to get your blood pressure
under control
i say if i wasn't so tired all the time
i think the blood pressure would
correct itself yeah um who do you hang
out with who are some buddies you might
have or some friends you might have
i don't really i'm pretty much at hermit
how come uh it's pretty much who i've
been all my life
yeah um what makes you laugh what brings
you joy
uh i don't know about laugh but i you
know
sunsets and sunrises and
pretty days and you know
wildlife things like that um that i mean
you can just
makes you know that there's days worth
living yeah
what makes you have days that you wonder
if they are worth living
i i don't think i have an issue with
that i just
have an issue with wondering how i'm
going to keep on
i don't i don't i don't feel like i
ever have days i just you know there's
days when you
it hurts and it's hard to keep moving
and you wonder if you're going to be
able to keep
keep going yeah that may be what you
mean right there
yeah what what scares you about the
future of the world
about the world about about the next 10
15 years in your life what what makes
you nervous what makes you a little bit
anxious he makes you want to go out and
go for a walk in
on one of those trails that you help
support
um
i just not being able to uh
you know pay the bills and you know have
a place to live and
afford a doctor you know that's like i
said i didn't
plan for my plan was just to keep on
working forever but i
find out that it's not an option harder
and harder huh
so do you love your job are you open to
getting a new job
to doing something different
well i i i love
where i work at and being outdoors and
i've got i've got uh nine years invested
in it
yeah and it's got a retirement and all
that and i just don't
think that's something i can turn my
back on so when you say
i don't know i'm gonna keep the lights
on keep the bills
paid um be able to afford a doctor
you say you got a retirement at some
point you have some sort of social
security is there something deeper
or is this just a math problem and
you're just man i did the math
it's gonna be tough or are you in a
predicament where
i really love my job and my body is
going to allow me to do this job much
longer and i'm going to have to figure
out something else to do i just really
don't want to
well
the math problem is just
not sure that what little money is going
to come in is going to be enough and i'm
not enough of a mathematician to
know that and the physical part is
yeah i i wouldn't mind you know i was
i in what i do
there's jobs where you can work
part-time and
work in parks and travel a little bit
and to me that sounds real cool
yeah and so i just
i don't want to be a burden to my son or
to anybody
so you know i want to be able to support
myself until like
until you know it's not needed anymore
yeah
so here's a couple things i just want to
pass along to you um
and you may know this stuff and man
brian you may have the phone and say
that guy's
full crap and it is what it is but
um i want you to hear a couple of things
that are
that are profound truths that i've seen
firsthand okay
number one
i don't care how texan you are how
strong you are how old you are how
anything you are
every single one of us myself included
brother and i hear
you and my voice i hear so many men my
friends dads
in your voice something about you
rings some a bell in my soul in a way
that i haven't had it wrong in a long
time
and um i need you to hear that
people would benefit
and would love having brian in their
life my gut tells me you got some
stories and you've got some experiences
and you've got a heart for service you
love working outside taking care of
things behind the scenes for people so
they can enjoy these parks
you have single-handedly duck kept the
stitching and duct tape fabric of our
society together
by keeping these parks open during cover
the last year so people could get
outside
and the the
phrase i'm just a hermit i just like to
be by myself i get that man i get it so
much that's my tendency but i want you
to know
that value and wellness and wholeness
and this idea that i can't wait to wake
up tomorrow
comes from one thing and that's from
being connected to other people
the second thing i want you to know is
um
this is a challenge this is a friendly
challenge to a guy
like i'm considering you my new friend
my mom took a new job at the age of 57
and she hadn't been in the workforce
much in her whole life
and she went to school she at 57 she got
a job
and now at age of 70 she's making more
money than she's ever made in her entire
life
she's had this whole wild second life
and then her 60s she wouldn't get on an
airplane
she just didn't like to fly she just
wouldn't do it and now she jet sets all
over
planet earth from wales to teaching in
london she's a professor now all over
the place
and this is somebody that never went to
college until her first community
college class was the age of 42.
and i just want to tell you whatever you
want to do man
where you're in a slice of history where
you can get any new education
for free if not for cheap you can find
people who will rally around you new
opportunities there
in san antonio day after day after day
i don't want you to pin him yourself in
and say this is just
is what it is what it is and i'm
destined for
this being the period at the end of my
life the last part of your life can be
whatever kind of adventure you want to
wrap around it
and the third thing i want to tell you
with with all my heart
i get the sentiment that you don't want
to be a burden to your son
this guy that it's a great human being
that everybody around him loves
but i want you to flip that around and i
want you to sit down and talk to him and
tell them
hey young man i want you to know that i
love you i'm really proud of you
everybody i talk to talks about how
great you are and i think you're great
and i also want you to know i need some
help planning for the future
um 20 year old brian didn't care about
60 year old brian and by the way
very few 20 year olds carry about their
60 year old selves right
but i want you to tell him you're lonely
i want you to tell him you love him i
want you to
tell him that you'd love to have him in
your life
and here's the thing you may think
you're going to be a burden to him but
you may flip that around and be an
extraordinary blessing to him
you may be able to open up parts of him
when it comes to empathy
parts of service he may not know how to
ask hey dad how can i
lean into your life and help and be
someone who cares about you and loves
you
so give him an opportunity to love and
care for you the way you loved and cared
for him for all those years
that doesn't mean he's going to pay your
rent doesn't mean you're going to move
into the room down by his bedroom right
but it may mean that y'all gonna have a
future together and be a lot
closer a lot more intertwined um i'm so
grateful for
the my dad at age 68 got a new job and
he's
man he is rocking it um i'm here talking
about my mom my dad too
and my relationship to my mom and my dad
continues to go deeper and continue to
go deeper because they're vulnerable i'm
vulnerable and we're figuring it out
together
but i think you're somebody worth
relationships brother and
i'm going to challenge you to start
thinking about new careers
that's going to pay you more that's
going to give you more spark i want to
challenge you to join some organizations
around where you live whether that's a
bird watching group or a hiking group or
a something group
and be uncomfortable take that hermit
and say i know i'd rather just stay in
bed but not today
today i'm gonna go be around people and
i know it's co i know all that stuff
but i want you to really double down on
meeting new people and reaching out to
folks
and i want you to have a conversation
with your son tell him you love him tell
him you're thinking about what the
future is going to look like and you
want him to be a part of it but you
don't want to be a burden to him and let
him speak into your heart and mind
so brian thank you so much for calling
me back and for um
just being vulnerable and being open i
hope you'll go see a doctor
and more importantly than a doctor right
now you've been to a doctor
and um man you've gotten some physical
care they talked about your blood
pressure if you want to really be brave
you want to really be tough i'd
encourage you to go see a counselor
somebody who's going to you can say hey
i'm 60.
i'm on the i'm on the back half man not
a lot of people live it to 120. so who
knows how long you're going to live
brian but you're on the back half
and i want to live well i don't want to
live with joy i want to laugh
a lot and they're going to give you some
skills walk alongside you
talk you through some things give you
some opportunities to grow and make the
last
10 20 30 years you got left a an
adventure so that you
hit home basement with no tread left on
brian's tires
no tread left on the tires brother thank
you so much for calling
those are my challenges here's the thing
i hope you'll have those conversations i
hope you'll start reaching out and i
hope you'll give me a call back in a
couple of months and let me know how
you're doing how things are going
i love talking to you like i say man you
remind me so much of
the men who have spoken into my life
over the years man it's just awesome to
talk to you
all right let's go to grant in flagstaff
brother grant how are we doing
hey i'm good doctor john how are you
doing i'm doing all right brother
so what's going on man yeah yeah i just
wanted to say man i've been listening
since august
and uh you just i know you give me so
much hope and you
i i look at you i'm 26 and you're the
kind of man i want to be
uh especially when i become your age
you're the first person that's ever said
that so thank you man
you get like i said you give me a lot of
hope um i i started a gratitude journal
um i i kind of developed a morning
routine i did the sugar thing and i just
i really enjoy listening to you from
driving to work
uh during the week but um so my question
for you
is i'm getting married in june um like i
said i'm 26
getting married in june and i have a
two-year-old daughter
of my own and my fiance has a
three-year-old daughter
and kids seem a little overwhelming to
me at times and
you know i have to and one and a half as
i like to say and so i
i want to know how do i be a you know
how do i be a great husband how do i be
a great dad
and how do i be a great stepdad um it
all kind of just seems overwhelming at
times
yeah yeah that's right dude it's
overwhelming for sure man
um i just want to stop the show for a
second man and just tell you i
appreciate you
and i love your heart brother and um
thinking ahead if every man would just
stop and pause and say
this is a lot and i want to be good at
this and i want to do this right
and i want to pick up some tools early
on man good for you man good for you
for setting an example for your kids and
for every guy who's listening to this
thing
every guy listening listen to grant be
that guy
okay all right so two-year-old of your
own
uh a three-year-old of your own
two-year-old coming in with a fiance is
that right
two-year-old of my own three-year-old
coming in with a fiancee both girls
okay 26 what do you do for a living man
i work in aviation so i uh
i manage like ground handling of like
aircraft
oh she like know how to do a thing
unlike me who just runs his mouth for a
living that's pretty awesome
okay so tell me what happened in with
um baby mama with you the mother of your
daughter
man you want you want the whole story
she wants a short story
give me the short one uh so i met her in
college
i was going to college um met her
we dated for five years um
we had an abortion um kind of dark part
of my life
and when i tried to end things um i
ended up
having a baby um and so uh tried to kind
of make things work
you end relationships way different than
i used to but go ahead yeah
yeah a little bit of a surprise but
anyway it says
you know pretty dramatic part of my life
kind of stressful part of my life but um
so anyways uh my daughter came into the
world tried to make things work and i
just realized
you know at the end of the day me
marrying somebody that i'm not happy
with
is way worse than you know uh
being the best dad i can be to her and
us not being married
um so i see her a couple times a week i
have a
pretty good relationship with with her
mom i'm not the best at times if she's
somebody that kind of struggles with
some
some uh mental maybe instability uh
she's
just had her own past and so um but i i
have a good relationship not a
not a great relationship like i said i'd
like it to be better but a good
relationship
further um yeah and
tell me why you're getting married to
this new woman
um so she just
she's everything i could hope for and a
partner um i think the thing you know my
parents always told me growing up is oh
when you meet the right person you know
you'll just know that they're the right
person and
i didn't really believe that to be
honest and this
this woman came into my life and
everything's just
she's so easy to get along with that
she's a christian she shares the same
fees as me the same morals as me
she grew up but a pretty much identical
uh
you know family life with with married
parents and just
siblings and she has two siblings and i
have two siblings and we just
really get along you know of all the
stress in my day managing people
being around you know loud airplanes and
everything else i come home to her
that's just it's
it's easy um it's not easy having a
three-year-old but
you know it's it's um she just she makes
me
the best version of me that that i can
be cool
so do you still have a good relationship
with your parents
yeah i do um having to have it you know
having a baby out of wedlock
my mom reminds me constantly about how i
sinned um
so i'm telling you right now no you
don't have a good relationship with your
parents
yeah not as not as great as i would hope
um
no hey that's not a good relationship
with your parents
well maybe maybe your old man but um
geez louise okay
all right so how do you be the best dad
you can be right
right and so here's why i asked you
those questions i want to paint a
picture because every dad's a little bit
different
and every dad's bringing different
bricks in their backpack to
this wild adventure of parenting
okay and every dad has got different
things on the table there's some things
that we all need to be doing in common
then there's some things that are going
to be very specific to each one of us
okay so i'm going to rattle a bunch of
stuff off here
as i go okay and you can either write
this down or you can just keep this
podcast forever or go onto the youtubes
internets and
cut and paste it and hold on to it okay
okay
here's number one um you've got to love
your new wife you have to model it you
have to love her
like crazy okay
this relationship is about you and your
new wife
this relationship is about y'alls coming
together and being in love
and all that fun stuff and it's also
modeling for these two
young baby girls
what it looks like to be treated by
somebody who loves you
okay so you'll be a walking
a walking college course to your baby
girls on this is what love
looks like this is what i deserve this
is what somebody who says the words i
love you
this is what they do so you have to go
out of your way to
love that woman like crazy
okay my guess is by the way your mom
talks to you
and the challenges you've had in the
past you're gonna need some skills
some new skills that's not a bad thing i
don't know many guys who don't need new
skills when they enter into
relationships
okay um that we'll talk about that in a
second so number two
is never ever ever talk bad
about your the mother of your girl
don't ever talk bad about the ex husband
ex the father of what's soon to be
you know your fiance's baby girl and
your
baby girl number two okay you're
modeling here's what relationships look
like here's what reconciliation looks
like here's what people who have had
challenges in the past here's how they
treat each other with dignity and
respect
count on problems over the years
count on there to be struggles there to
be custody issues count on all of that
decide before you get married decide
before you take on another daughter into
your
into your world i'm gonna be this type
of person
i'm not gonna go to war i'm not gonna
yell i'm gonna do what's right
right and i'm gonna um if there's
injustice i'm gonna be right there in
the middle of it but i'm gonna do it
with dignity and do with respect right
um number three say i love you every
single solitary day of these young girls
lives
and hold their face and say it into
their eyeballs so they can see you
okay there will be days when they don't
want to hear it they're gonna be like no
dad matt they're gonna say i don't care
you will hear the words out of my mouth
every day that i love you right high
touch
high touch and here's a a key and i'm i
got a five-year-old daughter and so i'm
wrestling with this right now and it's
hard for me
but i i think i'm getting it right and
that is this
and sometimes my wife has to say ah i'm
like
i knew it okay it's this it's really
high touch
with autonomy what does that mean that
means
i want my daughter to know that i love
her more than anything
and i also want her to know i want to
teach her at a young age
that she is in control of her body
what does that mean on on the ground
that means
i might say hey come give your daddy a
hug and she'll say
no daddy because she's being silly or no
daddy i don't want to hug you
i can then say i told you to come give
me a hug
or i can run over there and grab her and
force her to
what am i telling her that at some point
some guy who's bigger and stronger can
say
no you will love me and it will look
like this
and i ultimately because i have bigger
stronger muscles i'm in control of your
body
and i don't want her to ever feel that
so i'm teaching her a young age
she's in control of her body i'm not
gonna weaponize my love i'd say hey baby
come snuggle with dad and she says no i
wanna sit over here
from that point forward it's about me i
want her to come snuggle with me she
doesn't want to
i gotta go cool hope you're having fun
over there on that side of the couch and
then i'm gonna go about watching my show
because i'm not gonna i'm not gonna get
into it right
but it's about high touch with autonomy
and what i'll tell you is
saying i love you every day they can be
tough and silly but me when it comes to
bedtime when it comes to quiet time when
it comes to reading stories
when we read stories to our kids every
single night of the week
man that touch comes man they crave it
they just want to fall into it and so
it's letting it happen naturally
sometimes i gotta go to bed and be like
well my daughter hates me
she doesn't she's being five right um
get on the floor and wrestle with these
little girls let them know that you care
about them
act interested in dragons and ponies and
baby dolls and frogs and trucks and
hammers whatever the thing is
make that the most exciting important
thing when you're down on the ground
with them
don't go down there with your cell phone
right take care of yourself
eat right exercise have friends model
what friendship looks like
last two things are you ready yep be
really slow with advice
and really long on presents
most dads love to love their daughters
by telling them info well you know what
you should do is
this i would if i was you i would go do
this thing
oh you need to tell that teacher that
guy that ah man
most of us our daughters are really
really really smart and intuitive
you know what they really need is us to
get down on a knee and look them in the
eye and say i love you and i'm so sorry
that happened that stinks
or oh my goodness i can't wait to see
that dragon come show it to me again
or sure i'll put my phone down to read
you this book right here in the middle
of the living room floor let's just do
it right here
that tells a young girl i matter i've
got value my daddy loves me
and the last thing is this often guys
dads
they will be great fathers they'll
they'll do their best they'll plug in
and then they'll go work on their car
then they'll go get the oil change then
they'll go to the bank they'll go do
these other
things that unfortunately have been
gendered and domesticated right this is
what guys do and this is what girls do
as many places you can possibly take
those two girls take him with you
take him to help you make him get out of
the car with you if you gonna go play
catch bring him along with you if you're
going to a buddy's house help mow the
lawn bring them along with you
let them be involved in the day-to-day
rhythms of your
life no matter how quote-unquote boy of
a job it is i just hate all that crap
bring them along with you bring them
hunting bring them fishing
bring them everywhere with you um if you
play call of duty just stop playing
video games but other than that bring
them with you right
ah there you go you're my man grant
bring them with you
and just set up your life to where your
buddies know hey when i go out
um my daughters are coming with me
because i love them and they're awesome
and they're rad
and they will get to watch dad have
friends they'll get to watch
who dad really is and that will
shape-shift everything about their life
and then the last last last thing i
already said the last thing i got one
more thing
okay how how bold do you want to be
brother how good of a dad you want to be
old and courageous all right i want you
to go see a counselor for your trauma
i want you to go see somebody have you i
well so i wanted to it's kind of a side
note so i did see
counselors through the you know the
traumatic stuff with with my baby mama
but i just you had said a while back you
know universities have
uh you know counselors and trainings
reach out to you practical labs whatever
so i reached out beginning of the year
and they paired me up with this guy
and the first counselor had was a girl
but they paired me up with this app the
one i had a couple years ago but the
the the student one that i have is a guy
and i met with him yesterday for the
first time in person
um because i got my covet shot and they
they're letting us like meet face to
face and so anyways
um i just i don't know i don't really
seem to click with him
um and i just i don't know do i keep
going to him dr john or
do i just stop it now like i usually
recommend folks go two or three times
and if you don't click you don't click
and then you move on
don't judge him by how tall he is or how
much hair he's got or
how high or low his voice is or anything
like that um
be as vulnerable as you can okay be open
and vulnerable tell the truth
the whole truth all of it even with me
just now i'm not calling you alive i'm
saying like
like hey how's your relationship with
your parents they're great my mom
reminds me what a
what a failure i am right so be honest
about your past your childhood the stuff
your parents expected of you the way
they still beat you up even though
you're 26 with almost two kids
all those things be honest in these
sessions give this
well john john one thing that he said
was
you know i went and saw this counselor
for two years and i never really
like i couldn't even tell you i don't
know what her husband's name was you
know like and obviously it's i'm not
there to be friends like you talk about
but
you know i said i'd like to little know
a little bit more about you because you
know he's like 28 29
where are you from um you know where'd
you go where'd you get your underground
and like he said well
you're making me uncomfortable grant
like why are you asking me this and
and i understand where he's coming from
like yeah you know they
obviously got to protect herself as a
professional but on the flip side i said
well i want to be able to relate you
know i feel like you know i listen to
you every week like i relate to you
yeah um or do you think that's
irrelevant john like
yeah i think um my guess is that's a
go in there to get some help and not to
build bridges
okay um yeah counselors are trained not
to make it about them
and usually when somebody starts digging
into their past
where did you go to school why are you
doing this where are you from how many
kids do you have
that's usually about the the the patient
the clients trying to do some distancing
trying to get some things there
take some ownership of that relationship
man you're in there to learn some skills
and to get well the
the relationship matters for sure um but
i wouldn't go in there asking a bunch of
questions i'd go in there ready to go
okay go in there ready to go trust this
person wouldn't be in there if they
didn't know what they were doing
and if you get in and you just don't
feel comfortable man ask for another
therapist
it's simple this is about you you're not
in there to make a therapist feel good
about themselves they're grown up big
boys and girls
if a client says i don't want to work
with you because i'm not feeling a
connection
sweet we're moving on to the next thing
same thing here
you go find somebody that you're
connected to okay make that a priority
but yeah don't go in there asking a
bunch of questions about their family
and things like that it doesn't matter
it's not relevant you think that's going
to help you build a relationship it's
not it's a stalling technique it's a
punting technique
for you to make sure you've got control
that situation part
of counseling is going there and being
vulnerable and
i'm just going to lay it all out here in
a safe space this person said they're
not going to judge me this person's
going to walk alongside me
go in there and just put it all down
okay go in there and put it all down
um grant the fact that you're asking
these questions tells me you're gonna be
a good guy
a good dad go in there ready to rock and
roll keep this
little video clip with you tell those
girls you love them
be connected to them and us above all
else
do your work on yourself and love love
love their mom show that mom that you
love her every day
all right so i get a question with some
regularity about
the meditation the box breathing thing
so
um i got the box breathing from mark
devine he's a navy seal he's got an
awesome podcast too if you want to check
it out
um he is a a navy seal trainer i think i
think he trains
future navy seals he's just smart and
he's awesome so
um here's how the box breathing works
and we'll just do it really quick here
on on the show it works like this
when you get stressed when you feel your
heart rate taking off on you and you
still
feel your stomach drop when you've got
to go do something hard you have to give
a speech in a class you got to study you
got to go have this hard conversation
admit something to your wife that you've
been holding back on a long time
a way to reset your physiology almost
instantaneously is this
box breathing you breathe up for four
you hold it for four you exhale for four
you hold it for four
that's it we can do it real quick right
here ready
i'm nervous i'm nervous here we go up
hold it exhale
two three four hold it
and you do it again do that ten times
and your entire body
goes whoosh
if you learn to do it while you're
walking it's even better
it's become part of my rhythm when i'm
going for a walk
just do box breathing while i'm walking
and you get to where you can hold your
breath for six
counts 10 counts 15 counts you just
begin to build up a reservoir of
peace and what happens over time is you
start to get control of your breath
you get control of your heart rate
starting to take off on you
you get control of your head right when
you're gasping for air
when you're on 10 or 11 you're running
out of error you get to
learn how to just calm your body down
when it's screaming at you right
so um box breathing it's just a quick
technique it's simple it's something i
use
all the time almost probably on a daily
basis um
just and it's just become part of my
natural rhythm for getting in and out of
a day so
that's it for that all right let's take
one more call let's go to
elizabeth in morgantown west virginia
elizabeth what's going on hi thank you
for taking my
uh call thank you for calling what's
going on
well i am a mother of two adopted
kids three and six oh
you are actually let's pause right there
you're in it
yep you're super in it right
yeah open or closed adoptions
uh closed okay so you're
super super super in it are you married
yes
okay and um ever since we adopted these
girls as they came into our lives
we've my husband and i have not been
intimate so i feel like we're a roommate
okay and then i i'm a teacher also
so with covet and everything i like my
job duties have like doubled
so i kind of feel stressed and
frustrated with everything and everyone
yeah and i find myself yelling at my
girls
and i just um i
don't like don't know how to be
the um christian mother and wife that i
want to be
in my situation
that sucks i'm sorry
i just i hate all that for you i know
it's exhausting man and
being on an island by yourself sucks and
i'm sorry um
when did the girls come home did they
come together
no yeah they're they're siblings okay
they came same time
how long have they have they been there
uh
three years now so you and your husband
haven't slept together for three years
no tell me about that
what was that off swish that happened
when you brought the girls home
i i honestly i don't know i
asked my husband about it and he said
well we've got two
little ones in the house or yeah or so
tired
and you know and that's basically
about the just of it you know
what was your relationship like before
you brought these kids home
i'd say it was it was pretty good um
you know i mean i was a stepmother
to two sons and then they grew up
and left the house and um so
i don't know um the conflicts with
uh how he disciplined them but since he
was their biological
you know father uh he did you know
basically
all of the disciplining and um
so i don't i don't know i mean i guess i
really should aspire and we
we have a lot of agreements on things
like um
my spiritual beliefs and
we enjoy reading um but
we don't have a lot in common other than
that i guess
and how old are you no how old am i 62.
52. and my husband's 61. 61.
okay have y'all
the pursuits you talked about were all
cognitive
they're all informational we like to put
information into the front of our brains
together other than that we don't have a
lot
and so what i'll tell you is
other people who share the joy of
shoving information
into the front of their brains are you
know professional colleagues
and like you mentioned roommates and
people who sit next to each other in
college classes right
not husbands and wives right
have y'all ever gone to see somebody
we did and um he basically
said well you know it's really you that
needs to see a counselor
and so i just automatically stopped it
so you and your husband went and saw a
counselor and then he after seeing a
counselor he looked at you and said
you're the one with the problems
pretty much yeah okay like you're the
one that needs to go to counseling and i
just
i said okay so we're not going because
if we don't if
two people you know aren't in agreement
with needing counseling it's not gonna
not gonna help so
yes you can't go three years without
having sex in your marriage
particularly if one of you is dying on
the vine i'm telling you something you
don't know right you know this
um
the way you keep yourself staved off
from burnout
the way you keep yourself engaged
relationally the way
you keep your heart and mind tethered in
is
when you are fully connected when you
are fully known when you are intimate
with somebody
intimacy doesn't always have to be sex
okay
but intimate can be
we turn all the sound off in the house
and we sit down and talk to one another
every single night and we hold hands
every single day and yeah sexual
intimacy is a big part of that
and we i wake up every day with a desire
how can i make his life better what are
ways that i can show up
for what he needs and he wakes up with
that same thought about you
right and if you don't have that man
there you're you're end up being an
untethered
with everything you try to do and you
throw on top of that two
adopted baby girls who are adjusting to
all the trauma they've experienced
and are all over your house i can't even
imagine
i'm younger than you and i've got a
five-year-old and every day i think
i'm gonna sleep the rest of my life
starting right now right i can't imagine
how tired you guys are
at the same time that connection and
that intimacy is what fuels that
everything does that make sense yeah um
so here's where i'm going to disagree
with you
if your husband's not willing to go get
well he's got some challenges okay
there's something happened
of some sort of what i would call major
significance that you brought home these
two girls
and a switch flipped off in your home
and i'd have to spend some time with you
both directly
to really root that out and that's not
my job here
but there's man this just smells uh
reeks of
major trauma somewhere this week's of
something major
have has there ever been infidelity in
your home
no does your husband have a history of
abuse
no do you no i don't hit him no
no no no not not each other as people
ever hurt you and y'all's past
no okay um man there is something else
here
and it will exceed the scope of this of
this radio show
here's what i'm gonna disagree with you
on i'm gonna challenge you okay
um okay at the end of the day you can't
make him do anything right
right what you can do is learn some new
skills
work on you and so i think that in this
situation i can't recommend
more than enough if i'm you i'd be on
the call on the phone today going to see
somebody i'd be on the phone today
reaching out saying i want to see
somebody
i'm literally suffocating from
loneliness um
let a therapist know i am i am
truly interested in being intimate with
my husband and we haven't slept together
in three years
i've got two adopted young girls that
are driving us all ragged
and i've gotta i've gotta be well and
whole and
start working on yourself that's the
best you can do
five years from now you're gonna be five
years later right so you're 52 you're
gonna be 57 anyway
you can be 57 and have an 11 year old
and what a seven year old and be
further exhausted and further withered
out on that vine or
you can learn some more things about
yourself you can learn some new skills
you can at some point possibly model for
your husband what it looks like
and he's going to want to join you or he
may just opt out
he may just flat opt out but your
marriage
is on life support right now you need
one another in a
significant major way there's some other
stuff here like i keep saying
um and you need to take the first step
because why not because what i mean what
else you got to take the first step
um yeah elizabeth you got to go go go go
um when it comes to being a teacher and
all that there's a lot of resources
all of these resources stacked on top of
a foundation
of of a home marriage that's got a
such a crack in it as yours does isn't
going to help
so go get yourself whole go get yourself
well start learning new things
um process this as a trauma that it is
and then be about hey how do i deal with
burnout at work how do i
become a better mom to these kids et
cetera um
uh i'm heartbroken for you i hate it for
you i hate it for you elizabeth
go today and make that call go today
all right so if we end today's show
let's see here let's go
with you know what we're gonna go with
this song
i used to drive around my hometown in
houston texas
and listen to the this tape and i would
feel this song i would feel that i would
turn up so loud i'm probably
still deaf from that i would
listen to it and listen to it and
there's some screaming parts where he
just feels it and i'd be like
yeah and then for this show i was
thinking of songs i used to love as a
kid and i printed out the lyrics
i wasn't singing these lyrics i don't
even know where these come from
i don't know what i was saying but not
this
not this and so now i feel like all of
my childhood was a lie
because i don't know what happened but i
thought this song was way longer it's a
really long song and it's all into
i i missed it but here we go the
greatest song of all time
and this guy's emerged from the new
metal music and
man they're incredible i saw him live
once man it was an experience it was a
spiritual experience it was incredible
for off their 1997 around the fur record
the deftones yeah you that's what i'm
talking about the deft oh you were
telling me to look somewhere else i
thought you were cheering you're
pointing
i thought zach the video extraordinaire
back there was like yeah
he was pointing over here thanks man
the song is called be quiet and drive
far away
he sings this town don't feel mine i'm
fast to get away
far i dressed you in her clothes now
drive me far
away it feels good to know you're mine
now drive me far away far away
i don't care where just far i don't care
where just far
that's the whole song i don't know what
i was seeing my childhood it wasn't that
such is life my friends such as life
thank you for joining us this has been
the dr john delaney show
you